it's not even in the movie theaters yet
but guess what Wonder Woman is already
getting stellar reviews ahead of its big
screen debut this weekend actress gal
gadot plays Wonder Woman she first took
on the role back in 2016 in the film
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice the
new movie tells the story of Wonder
Woman's origins so she leaves her secret
island of Amazons and joins forces with
Captain Steve Trevor during World War
one give us dr. Mao's notebook alright
let that thing set back
or maybe not
[Music]
[Music]
let's just say she kicks them all down
and the guys are going what just
happened here this is the first
big-budget comic-book movie in Hollywood
history directed by a woman that woman
is patty Jenkins aka badass she joins us
at the table good morning to you patty J
morning hey I'm not an action movie girl
but I watched this movie and I thought
wow this is good but you took it to the
to the movie theaters to the movie
producers in 2005 it took this long to
get it made yeah I didn't exactly take
it to them but it was the the first time
you know after I had made monster and
you do the rounds and you meet at
studios
you know Superman one had been a huge
influence on my life so I'd always
wanted to do an origin superhero story
and when I realized like the math came
together and that nobody had ever done
Wonder Woman I was like what are we
crazy I don't - Wonder Woman I would
love to
so from 2005 for my first meeting with
them I was like I want to do Wonder
Woman and then we talked about it every
year or two
four till now tell me now you're the
first woman to direct a big-budget
yes movie of this con crazy but true and
do you think of yourself as a badass it
does everybody else does everybody else
is even in your fight scenes patty you
had a specific thing in mind even I just
marveled at the artistry of the fight
scenes saying what was your thinking
behind the fight scenes well you know
it's interesting because people say how
different was it doing action and I was
my actual answer is not that different
you direct them just like anything else
you you approach it from a character
point of view and what was fascinating
here was her objectives going to be a
little bit different than any superhero
movie I'd seen that was from a different
kind of character and from a man but you
gave specific direction yeah
well the interesting thing about her was
she never she doesn't enjoy she's a
super badass she doesn't enjoy violence
and there's a different tone to it so it
was even interesting working with some
of the stunt people and with our amazing
second unit director and like it's never
this it's this it's I'm up between the
two the difference between the two is
you're not I'm gonna get you it's not
where it's coming from
instead it's coming from here you come
boom gonna block you hear you it's it's
always staying present
in the moment almost more like a martial
artist present in the moment not
emotional not gleeful not rageful all of
those things and it was fight it was
fascinating to direct in that way the
whole mythology behind Wonder Woman is
always great to revisit yes everybody
knows Linda Carter and Wonder Woman
yeah but the story of the Amazons and
saving the world yeah what she's trying
to do yeah
that's my one of my favorite things
about Wonder Woman I mean you think
about it I couldn't believe the entire
time we were making this movie what was
in our hand
I thought of yes I love Wonder Woman but
also we were making a movie about
someone who wants to teach love and
truth in the world right now and who's
incredible and want to live up to
everything of a superhero movie but her
her message is but lay down those
weapons I believe in a better you in the
future which I love doesn't come from a
place of revenge no yeah no but also you
said it empowered you yeah idea a Wonder
Woman with an empowerment act for you
absolutely and the greatest thing for me
was I was that kid on the schoolyard who
saw Lynda Carter and went racing out to
when all of the other kids are playing
on the playground and said I would be
Wonder Woman you're always fighting with
every other girl to be Wonder Woman and
then when you were her in your head you
were like that bully over there I'm
gonna go stop them and I look like Lynda
Carter while I'm doing yeah it sounds
like there was this wish fulfillment of
being like the greatest version of
yourself of the woman you did she gave
you decide how to have that thought
absolutely and your mom do yes and your
mom made you super aware yeah of some of
the differences between men and women
but she also said in your dad too that
you can do anything yeah it was
interesting because my mother had really
been embroiled in the struggle of trying
to put us trying to get an education
trying to put herself through school as
a young mother all of those things but
somehow I came out of the whole thing
with the impression like oh wow that was
too bad mom lucky for us that those days
are over you know so I kind of just went
blindly into the future saying that's
that's great but that's all in the past
can't happy for people to see it Patti
thank you watching with my three kids
huge hit that [ __ ] Wonder Woman opens in
theaters nationwide tomorrow